I thought I'd take a page from Billy
Crystal and mr. Uyghur I hope you don't
mind but I'm borrowing a little
something from your library maestro
save the children 100 years we have
three lofty goals a healthy start for
kids the opportunity to learn and always
protect the young from harm perhaps you
remember the commercials Sally Struthers
some children and some flies for the
price of one coffee a day you could save
many children's lives and faraway places
[Music]
thank you to miss Winfrey and to mr.
Taylor for your time and for the power
of your attention and for mr. eager
under whose leadership the Walt Disney
Company has helped save the children
provide educational materials to over a
hundred thousand children in Nepal Haiti
and the United States my old pal thank
you so I'm just gonna say this part up
front
um for tonight's event we have partnered
with the great people at text to give
and right now although I think you
should probably wait until after Oprah
speaks you can pledge you can text to
zero three three zero nine can I
interrupt you for one second I really
started interrupts their speech but if
they made me do it this is all John Ross
made me do this
I just want to say that Jennifer has
done so much for Save the Children for
over ten years she's traveled the world
she is really like more than any other
celebrity you can name she is the one
raised tens of millions of dollars for
this organization and this is just a
small gift from Save the Children to you
thank you you for everything I'm sorry
for everything
god bless you
well okay thanks okay now I'm verklempt
I wasn't expecting that Thank You mr.
Carey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]